mesdames messieurs bon dimanche c'est un
échange corsé dans les images ont fait
le tour du monde juste un Trudeau
rabroué par son homologue chinois chez
Jinping pour avoir dévoilé le contenu
d'une première conversation concernant
l'ingérence chinoise dans les récentes
élections canadiennes le président chi a
évoqué l'importance des changes
respectueux sans lesquels les résultats
seraient imprévisibles Pékin accusé le
Canada de faire preuve de condescendance
les relations aussi nos canadiennes
étaient déjà bien difficiles dans quel
état sont-elles aujourd'hui j'ai posé la
question à Michael Chang le porte-parole
conservateur en matière d'affaires
étrangères mais d'abord l'extrait de
conversation captée par un caméraman
canadien
[Musique]
bonjour merci d'être avec nous merci
pour je suis heureux d'être ici si tu as
une commençons par la scène que l'on
vient de voir entre shugin et Justin
Trudeau qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé de
cette scène dans cette semaine
premièrement je pense que c'était un
grand manque de respect contre notre
premier ministre et le Canada je pense
que c'est clair Beijing ne respectent
pas le Canada j'ai pas je pense aussi
que cette à cause sur le fait que le
Canada n'a pas une politique claire
à Anvers la Chine
qui vont présenter un plan en reste ici
sans une plante en même temps monsieur
Trudeau c'est fait rabrouer par par
Monsieur chi parce qu'il avait exprimé
les doléances du Canada quant à la
potentielle incursion des Chinois ici
dans le système démocratique est-ce
qu'il a fait son travail en faisant ça
je pense que oui je pense que c'est
important pour un premier que la
Canadienne dire un chef étrangère que ce
pack acceptable pour un gouvernement
étrangère de faire des opérations des
ingérences étrangères ici au Canada mais
en même temps c'est plus important faut
notre premier ministre de mise en place
un plan ici au Canada pour arrêter ce
menace ici au Canada parce que c'est
c'est pas des opérations qui est dans la
Chine c'est des opérations ici au Canada
parlons du plan il y a une ébauche de
plan qui s'en vient madame je lis en a
présenté des pans avant de partir il y a
des gens qui disent on pouvait pas aller
dans on pouvait pas être trop dur envers
la Chine pendant la période des deux
mycoles là-bas et peut-être que ça
retardait le dépôt de ce plan là est-ce
que vous pensez que ça aurait dû être
déposé ou ça aurait dû être annoncé plus
rapidement à quel moment ça aurait dû
être fait je pense que le gouvernement a
besoin de présenter un plan il y a deux
ans il il y a trois ans même dans le
temps des deux Mako même pendant que les
deux mailles étant captivité absolument
parce qu'on en doit protéger sur les
citoyens canadiens et c'est pas possible
de protéger nos
intérêts nos valeurs nos citoyens si
nous n'avons pas un politique clair
envers la Chine mais le la politique du
gouvernement Trudeau envers la Chine
s'est confusant donc d'après vous il y a
de la confusion dans le discours
qu'est-ce que ça suicide comment c'est
élu comment s'est perçu par la Chine
d'après vous je pense que le Chine
prendre l'opportunité
avec ce politique confusion de menacer
le Canada donc il prend l'opportunité
pour faire des opérations ici parce que
le gouvernement du Canada n'a pas de
position claire
parlons justement de ce qui se passe ici
sur le terrain il y a eu cette
entreprise au Québec qui a été arrêté la
semaine dernière soupçonné l'espionnage
il y a ces allégations que la Chine
financée la campagne d'une douzaine de
candidats durant la dernière élection
fédérale la présence de poste de police
clandestin chinois au Canada qu'est-ce
qui vous inquiète
premièrement je suis heureux que
finalement notre force policière à
commencer de à rater ce menace de la
Chine avec
l'employé avec Hydro-Québec mais en même
temps nous sommes trop tard au
tempérament des autres tomates aussi
pour arrêter ce menace qu'est-ce que
vous voulez dire
par exemple aux États-Unis les forces
policiers
l'autopartment de la Justice
a déposer des accusations avec des
douzaines des des agents en chinois il y
a quelques années donc on a été un peu
trop permissif au Canada ou on n'a pas
on n'a pas pris cette menace là au
sérieux je pense que c'est les deux
choses on a été trop permissif le
gouvernement était le gouvernement est
un peu naïf le gouvernement est
un peu
désorganisé avec ce menace pourquoi les
gens parlons spécifiquement du
financement de certains candidats à la
dernière élection fédérale pourquoi
est-ce que ça devrait inquiéter les
Canadiens parce que
le rapport a dit qu'il y a des candidats
libéraux et conservateurs qui sont a
reçu des fonds et des dons chinois de la
de la de beaching c'est absolument
inacceptable mais c'est pas possible
pour nous comme consommateur c'est pas
possible pour tout le monde de
rater ce menace si nous n'avons pas les
noms les noms des candidats qui a reçu
ces dents vous avez vous avez réclamé
les noms à plusieurs reprises pourquoi
c'est important qu'est-ce que ça fait
qu'est-ce qui arrive si l'un des
candidats a été élu
on doit commencer à investigation pour
déterminer si les candidats a connu
qu'ils ont reçu ces donne si oui je
pense que c'est une enjeu criminal et
c'est une question de l'intrigue
de nos députés de nos candidats dans une
action c'est très difficile pour nous de
arrêter ce menace mais on doit le faire
à cause l'intégrité de notre signe de
deux ou trois derniers petits éléments
vous avez parlé de l'importance
d'établir une politique
à l'endroit de la Chine la stratégie et
nos Pacifique c'est comme ça que le
gouvernement l'appelle est-ce qu'on peut
se permettre est-ce qu'on peut se passer
de faire des affaires avec la Chine
la Chine s'atteine elle part de
l'économie mondiale c'est clair mais en
même temps le communauté
d'une intelligence canadienne a dit il y
a 5 domaines sensitifs que la Chine
menace le Canada c'est dans le domaine
de
télécommunication
les domaines de biotechnologie
le domaine de intelligence artificielle
et quelques autres domaines et dans ce 5
domaines le gouvernement a besoin de
diriger
les fonds pour les recherches
développement pour nous universités ils
ont besoin de ne pas donner des fonds
publics pour des partenaires avec les
entités chinois et deuxièmement ils ont
besoin de faire leur avis à les
universités et aux provinces
de faire le même chose à quel point
est-ce qu'on doit être inquiet de ce que
représente Pékin comme menace pour le
Canada je pense que on doit 13 ans qui
est très très inquiète c'est clair
pendant la dernière 56 ans que
présidenti c'est un président différent
que tous les autres présidents avant
le président Mao de la Chine et c'est un
président qui amasse le pouvoir dans un
grand manière et qui veut exporter son
système autoritaire pendant le monde et
il utilise tous les tu les utiles pour
faire pour le faire ici au Canada et
dans les autres démocraties merci
beaucoup merci